I am the himalayan foothills the Yangtze
plunges through steep gorges creating
Rapids that can take your breath away
for decades now adventurers have been
navigating through the spectacular bend
in the world's third longest river but
now a group of Chinese and international
conservationists and researchers have
gathered for what may be the final run
China is building a series of dams on
this part of the river that will change
it forever
Travis Winn is leading what's been
called the last descent River expedition
our pool our mission right now
is to figure out the fastest way to
bring as much attention to these rivers
as possible to get people to really
think
understand and individually personally
reached the conclusion their work
the team will paddle a 120 mile stretch
known as the Great Bend it's far
upstream of the famed and massive three
gorges dam but several other dams
smaller than the three gorges are being
built in this area they'll provide
electricity for the Chinese people like
the Three Gorges it's expected they will
also alter the landscape by backing the
river into reservoirs not many Chinese
descend these Rapids and when and his
team hope this trip will bring national
attention to the threatened resource you
bring people River you see them change
and their attitude about
both the natural world these rivers and
the way they live their lives at home
changes it takes the group seven days to
journey downstream passing a landscape
on the brink of change they may be the
last outsiders to see this stretch of
the Yangtze in its pristine State it was
very narrow very steep canyon walls and
on the left-hand side of river going
down there was waterfall we spent
probably a good half hour to an hour
there just marveling at its beauty I
almost found myself doing it knowing
that this canyon would be flooded in
probably a year or so and all of this
would be lost not just to us but more
importantly to the Chinese and it's so
few of us very few of us who have had a
chance to experience this place
National Geographic young explorer trip
Jennings was gratified to see the
Chinese expedition members realize the
beauty of whitewater
we're these dams are going to be built
before we came they're already under
construction but everything changes when
you gain this kind of intimate
understanding we thought Chinese
participants who thought enjoying rivers
like this was for crazy professionals
and now they've turned around and
they're buying kayaks I think that's the
biggest success of this trip enabling
people in China to experience these
resources as more than just hydropower
but the expedition is powerless to stop
the inevitable or the end of their
journey the fate of the great fin seems
sealed you can see right up here why
this is going to be a last ascent if you
look at the bridge of another and only
150 feet above the bridge is a dam it's
being built over it and all this is
going to be inundated all that really
fun whitewater we just ran all that
beautiful scenery most of those pretty
little villages they're all gonna be
underwater win hopes the delay in the
building schedule will allow him just
one more trip down the Great Bend of the
Yangtze but at some point the flow of
this powerful river will be stopped by
the flow of development
sponsored by National Geographic mission
programs taking science and exploration
into the new millennium